uh but no but yeah so Chris Pratt was we
were at a restaurant and I go
guys don't freak out but
Guardians of the Galaxy you know and my
daughter's like oh my God
you know and then the nine-year-old
who's was eight at the time was like I I
know his son
and I go really she's like yes I know
his son can I go over there and say hi
we walk over there
I tap on the shoulder hey Chris sorry
but my daughter knows your son and my
daughter goes I don't know his son
you wanted to meet Chris Pratt
and Chris Pratt's like this
[Laughter]
I wanted to strangle her but I was also
never more proud as a kid in my life
where I was like and I go why did you do
that and she was like I don't know and I
was like you're gonna make me so much
money